CARMEN MARIA MACHADO:
Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
It's really lovely to see you.
I'm incredibly
excited to be here.
If anyone is hiring a fiction
writer here at Google,
please email me.
I like your kitchens.
[LAUGHTER]
And I want just an endless
supply of seltzer water.
It's, like, my absolute
dream in this world.
So today I am
going to be reading
from "Her Body and
Other Parties,"
and I wanted to briefly
talk about the collection
before I started reading.
And I'm actually going to read
you an entire story, which
I'm extremely excited about
because at readings I almost
never get to read
an entire story,
and it makes me real cranky.
I hate doing excerpts, so
I'm very excited to give you
an entire story.
I'm stoked.
I haven't done that in ages.
So yeah, "Her Body
and Other Parties"
is a collection of
short stories that
does a lot of sort of
genre-bending material,
or has a lot of
genre-bending material.
The story I'm going to read you
the only sort of pure science
fiction story in the collection.
Most of the stories
are sort of fabulist,
kind of deal with sort of
surrealist, subliminal fantasy,
that sort of area.
This one just happens to be
my science fiction story.
And I'm really interested
in using fiction
to sort of explore and examine
questions about women's lives.
And that includes sex, gender,
sort of intellectual problems
that women experience uniquely
in their lives in terms of,
how do we tell stories
about women that
talk about mental health without
falling into traps of, say,
writing a crazy woman story
or like a crazy lesbian story,
for example?
So this is just really
interesting to me
and is really important to me.
And I've been working on these
stories for about five years.
And then I finally
had a book's worth,
which is pretty exciting.
Yeah, so the story I'm going
to be reading you today
is called "Inventory."
"Inventory."
One girl.
We lay next to each other on
a musty rug in her basement.
Her parents were upstairs.
We told them we were watching
"Jurassic Park," "I'm the dad
and you're the mom," she said.
I pulled up my shirt
and she pulled up hers,
and we just stared
at each other.
My heart fluttered somewhere
below my belly button,
but I worried about Daddy
Long Legs and her parents
finding us.
I still have never
seen "Jurassic Park."
I suppose I never will now.
One boy, one girl.
My friend.
We drank stolen wine
coolers in my room
on the vast expanse of my bed.
We laughed and talked and
passed around the bottles.
"What I like about you," she
said, "is your reactions.
You respond so
funny to everything,
like it's all intense."
He nodded in agreement.
She buried her face
in my neck and said,
"Like this," to my skin.
I laughed.
I was nervous, excited.
I felt like a guitar and someone
was twisting the tuning pegs
and my strings were
getting tighter.
They batted their
eyelashes against my skin
and breathed into my ears.
I moaned and writhed
and hovered on the edge
of coming for whole minutes even
though no one was touching me
there, not even me.
Two boys, one girl, one
of them my boyfriend.
His parents were out of town, so
we threw a party at his house.
We drank lemonade
mixed with vodka,
and he encouraged me to make out
with his friend's girlfriend.
We kissed tentatively
and then stopped.
The boys made out
with each other
and we watched them for a
long time, bored but too drunk
to stand up.
We fell asleep in
the guest bedroom.
When I woke up, my bladder
was tight as a fist.
I padded down to
the foyer and saw
someone had knocked a vodka
lemonade onto the floor.
I tried to clean it up.
The mixture had stripped
the marble finish bare.
My boyfriend's mother found my
underwear behind the bed weeks
later and handed them to him,
laundered, without a word.
It's weird to me how much
I miss that floral chemical
smell of clean clothes.
Now all I can think
about is fabric softener.
One man-- slender,
tall, so skinny I
could see his pelvic bone,
which I found strangely sexy.
Gray eyes, wry smile.
I had known him
for almost a year,
since the previous October when
we met at a Halloween party.
I didn't wear a costume.
He was dressed as Barbarella.
We drank in his apartment.
He was nervous and
gave me a massage.
I was nervous, so I let him.
He rubbed my back
for a long time.
He said, "My hands
are getting tired."
I said, "Oh, and
turned toward him.
He kissed me, his face
rough with stubble.
He smelled like yeast and the
top notes of expensive cologne.
He lay on top of me and
we made out for awhile.
Everything inside of
me twinged pleasurably.
He asked if he could
touch my breasts,
and I clamped his
hand around it.
I took off my shirt and I
felt like a drop of water
was sliding up my spine.
I realized this was
happening, really happening.
We both undressed.
He rolled the condom down
and lumbered on top of me.
It hurt worse than
anything ever.
He came and I didn't.
When he pulled out, the
condom was covered in blood.
He pulled it off
and threw it away.
Everything in me pounded.
We slept on a too-small bed.
He insisted on driving me back
to the dorms the next day.
In my room, I took
off my clothes
and wrapped myself in a towel.
I still smelled like him,
like the two of us together,
and I wanted more.
I felt good, like an adult who
has sex sometimes, and a life.
My roommate asked me
how it was, hugged me.
One man, a boyfriend--
didn't like condoms, asked
me if I was on birth control,
pulled out anyway.
A terrible mess.
One woman, on and off again
sort-of girlfriend, classmate
from Organization
of Computer Systems,
long brown hair
down to her butt.
She was softer than I expected.
I wanted to go down on her,
but she was too nervous.
We made out and she slipped
her tongue in my mouth.
And after she went
home, I got off twice
in the cool stillness
of my apartment.
Two years later, we had sex on
the gravel rooftop of my office
building.
Four floors below
our bodies, my code
was compiling in front
of an empty chair.
After we were done, I
looked up and noticed a man
in a suit watching
us from the window
of an adjacent skyscraper,
his hand shuffling around
inside his slacks.
One woman, round
glasses, red hair.
Don't remember where I met her.
We got high and fucked, and
I accidentally fell asleep
with my hand inside her.
We woke up pre-dawn and walked
across town to a 24-hour diner.
It drizzled, and when we
got there our sandalled feet
were numb with chill.
We ate pancakes.
Our mugs ran dry, and when
we looked for the waitress
she was watching the breaking
news on the battered TV hanging
from the ceiling.
She chewed on her lip
and the pot of coffee
tipped in her hand,
dripping tiny brown dots
on the linoelum.
We watched as the newscaster
blinked away and was replaced
with a list of
symptoms of the virus
blossoming a state away
in Northern California.
When he came back, he repeated
that the planes were grounded,
the border of the
state had been closed,
and the virus appeared
to be isolated.
When the waitress walked
over, she seemed distracted.
"Do you have people there?"
I asked her, and she nodded,
her eyes filling with tears.
I felt terrible having
asked her anything.
One man-- I met him at
the bar around the corner
from my house.
We made out on my bed.
He smelled like sour
wine, though he'd
been drinking vodka.
We had sex, but he went
soft halfway through.
We kissed some more.
He wanted to go down on me,
but I didn't want him to.
He got angry and left,
slamming the screen door
so hard my spice rack
jumped from its nail
and crashed to the floor.
My dog lapped up
and nutmeg, and I
had to force feed him
salt to make him throw up.
Red from adrenaline,
I made a list
of animals I've had in my life--
seven, including
two beta fish who
died within a week
of each other when
I was nine, and a list
of the spices in pho--
cloves, cinnamon, star
anise, coriander, ginger,
cardamom pods.
One man, six inches
shorter than me.
I explained that the
website I was working for
was losing business rapidly
because no one wanted
quirky photography tips
during an epidemic,
and I'd been laid
off that morning.
He bought me dinner.
We had sex in his car,
because he had roommates
and I couldn't be in
my house right then,
and he slid his
hand inside my bra
and his hands were
perfect, fucking perfect,
and we fell into the
too-small backseat.
I came for the first
time in two months.
I called him the next day
and left him a voicemail,
telling him I'd had a good time
and I'd like to see him again,
but he never called me back.
One man, did some sort
of labor for a living.
I can't remember what exactly.
And he had a tattoo of a
boa constrictor on his back
with a misspelled
Latin phrase below it.
He was strong, could pick me
up and fuck me against a wall.
And it was the most thrilling
sensation I'd ever felt.
We broke a few picture
frames that way.
He used his hands and I dragged
my fingernails down his back,
and he asked me if I was
going to come for him.
And I said, "Yes.
Yes, I'm going to come for you.
Yes, I will."
One woman-- blonde hair, brash
voice, friend of a friend.
We married.
I'm still not sure if I was
with her because I wanted
to be or I was afraid of
what the world was catching
all around us.
Within a year, it soured.
We screamed more than we
had sex or even talked.
One night we had a fight
that left me in tears,
and afterwards she asked
me if I wanted to fuck
and undressed before
I could answer.
I wanted to push
her out the window.
We had sex and I started crying.
When it was over and she was
showering, I packed a suitcase
and got in my car and drove.
One man, six months later
in my post-divorce haze--
I met him at the funeral
for the last surviving
member of his family.
I was grieving.
He was grieving.
We had sex in the
empty house that
used to belong to his brother
and his brother's wife
and their children, all dead.
We fucked in every room,
including the hallway,
where I couldn't bend my
pelvis right on the hard floor
and so I jerked him off in
front of the bare linen closet.
In the master bedroom, I caught
my reflection in the vanity
mirror as I rode him,
and the lights were off
and our skin reflected
silver from the moon.
And when he came in
me he said, "Sorry.
Sorry."
He died a week later
by his own hand.
I moved out of the city, north.
One man, gray eyes again.
I hadn't seen him
in so many years.
He asked me how I
was doing, and I told
him some things and not others.
I did not want to cry
in front of the man
to whom I'd given my virginity.
It seemed wrong somehow.
He asked me how many I'd
lost and I said, "My mother.
My roommate from college."
I did not mention that
I'd found my mother died,
nor the three days afterward
I'd spent with anxious doctors
checking my eyes for
the early symptoms,
nor how I'd managed to
escape the quarantine zone.
"When I met you," he said,
"your were so fucking young."
His body was familiar,
but alien too.
He'd gotten better
and I'd gotten better.
When he pulled out I
almost expected blood,
but of course there was none.
He'd gotten more beautiful
in those intervening years,
more thoughtful.
I surprised myself by crying
over the bathroom sink.
I ran the tap so he
couldn't hear me.
One woman, brunette, a
former CDC employee--
I met her at a community
meeting where they taught us
how to stockpile food and manage
outbreaks in our neighborhood
should the virus
hop the firebreak.
I had not slept with
a woman since my wife,
but when she lifted
her shirt I realized
how much I'd been craving
breasts, wetness, soft mouths.
She wanted cock and I obliged.
Afterwards, she traced
the indents in my skin
from the harness
and confessed to me
that no one was having any
luck developing a vaccine.
"But the fucking
thing is only passing
through physical
contact", she said.
"If people just stayed apart."
She grew silent.
She curled up next to
me and we drifted off.
When I woke up, she was working
herself over with the dildo.
I pretended that I
was still sleeping.
One man-- he made me
dinner in my kitchen.
There weren't a lot of
vegetables left from my garden,
but he did what he could.
He tried to feed
me with a spoon,
but I took the handle from him.
The food didn't taste too bad.
The power went out for
the fourth time that week,
so we ate by candlelight.
I resented the
inadvertent romance.
He touched my face
when we fucked and said
I was beautiful, and I
jerked my head a little
to dislodge his fingers.
When he did it a second time,
I put my hand around his chin
and told him to shut up.
He came immediately.
I did not return his calls.
When the notice
came over the radio
the virus had reached Nebraska,
I realized I had to go east
and so I did.
I left my garden, the
plot where my dog was
buried, the pine table where I'd
anxiously made so many lists.
Trees that begin with M--
maple, mimosa, mahogany,
mulberry, magnolia, mountain
ash, mangrove, myrtle.
States that I'd lived in--
Iowa, Indiana, Pennsylvania,
Virginia, New York,
leaving unreadable
jumbles of letters
imprinted in the soft wood.
I took my savings and rented
a cottage near the ocean.
After a few months, the
landlord, based in Kansas,
stopped depositing my checks.
Two women, refugees
from the Western states
who drove and drove until
their car broke down
a mile from my cottage.
They knocked on my door and
stayed with me for two weeks
while we tried to figure out
how to get their vehicle up
and running.
We had wine one night and
talked about the quarantine.
The generator needed
cranking, and one of them
offered to do it.
The other one sat down next to
me and slid her hand up my leg.
We ended up jerking
off separately
and kissing each other.
The generator took and
the power came back on.
The other woman returned, and
we all slept in the same bed.
I wanted them to
stay, but they said
they were heading
up to Canada, where
it was rumored to be safer.
They offered to
bring me with them,
but I joked that
I was holding down
the fort for the United States.
"What state are we in?" one
of them asked, and I said,
"Maine."
They kissed me on the
forehead and turned.
and dubbed me the
protector of Maine.
After they left I only used
the generator intermittently,
preferring to spend time
in the dark with candles.
The former owner of the cottage
had a closet full of them.
One man, National Guard--
when he first showed
up to my doorstep,
I assumed he was
there to evacuate me.
But it turned out, he'd
abandoned his post.
I offered him a place
to stay for the night
and he thanked me.
I woke up with a knife to my
throat and a hand on my breast.
I told him I couldn't have sex
with him lying down like I was.
He let me stand up, and I
shoved him into the bookcase,
knocking him unconscious.
I dragged his body
out to the beach
and rolled it into the surf.
He came to sputtering sand.
I pointed the knife at him
and told him to keep walking,
and if he ever looked
back I would end him.
He obliged, and I
watched him until he
was a spot of darkness on
the gray strip of shore,
and then nothing.
He was the last person
I saw for a year.
One woman, a religious
leader with a flock of 50
trailing behind her,
all dressed in white.
For three days, I
made them wait around
the edge of the property.
And after I checked their
eyes, I permitted them to stay.
They all camped around
the cottage on the lawn,
on the beach.
They had their own
supplies and only needed
a place to lay their
heads, the leader said.
She wore robes that made
her look like a wizard.
Night fell.
She and I circled the
camp in our bare feet,
the light from the bonfire
carving shadows into her face.
We walked to the water's edge
and I pointed to the darkness
at a tiny island
she could not see.
She slipped her hand into mine.
I made her drink.
"More or less moonshine," I
said as I handed her the tumbler
and we sat at the table.
Outside I could hear people
laughing, playing music,
children romping in the surf.
The woman seemed exhausted.
She was younger than
she looked, I realized,
but the job was aging her.
She sipped her drink,
made a face at the taste.
"We've been walking
so long," she said.
"We stopped for a while,
somewhere near Pennsylvania.
But the virus caught up with
us when we crossed paths
with another group.
It took 12 of us before we got
distance between us and it."
We kissed deeply
for a long time,
my heart hammering in my cunt.
She tasted like smoke and honey.
The group stayed for four days,
until she woke up from a dream
and said she had an omen and
they needed to keep going.
She asked me to come with them.
I tried to imagine myself
with her, her flock
following behind
us like children.
I declined.
She left a gift on my
pillow, a pewter rabbit
as big as my thumb.
One man, no more than
20, floppy brown hair--
he'd been on foot for a month.
He looked like you'd expect--
skittish, no hope.
When we had sex, he was
reverent and too gentle.
After we cleaned up,
I fed him canned soup.
He told me about how he'd
walked through Chicago, actually
through it, how they'd stopped
bothering to dispose bodies
after a while.
He had to refill
his glass before he
talked about it further.
"After that," he said, "I
went around the cities."
I asked him how far behind
the virus was really,
and he said he did not know.
"It's so quiet here," he said,
by way of changing the subject.
"No traffic," I explained.
"No tourists."
He cried and cried, and I
held him until he fell asleep.
The next morning, I
woke up and he was gone.
One woman, much older than me--
while she waited for
three days to pass,
she meditated on a sand dune.
When I checked her
eyes, I noticed
they were green as sea glass.
Her hair grayed at her
temples, and the way
she laughed tripped pleasure
down the stairs of my heart.
We sat in the half
light of the bay window,
and the buildup was so slow.
She straddled me, and
when she kissed me
the scene beyond the
glass pinched and curved.
We drank and walked the
length of the beach,
the damp sand making pale
halos around our feet.
She told me about her once
childrens' teenage injuries,
having to put her cat to
sleep the day after she moved
to a new city.
I told her about finding
my mother, the perilous
trek across Vermont and New
Hampshire, how the tide was
never still, my ex-wife.
"What happened?" she asked.
"It just didn't work," I said.
I told her about the man
in the empty house, the way
he cried and the way his cum
shimmered on his stomach,
and how I could have
scooped despair from the air
by the handfuls.
We remembered commercial jingles
from our respective youths,
including one for an Italian
ice chain that I went to
at the end of long
summer days, where I
ate gelato drowsy in the heat.
I couldn't remember the last
time I had smiled so much.
She stayed.
More refugees filtered
through the cottage,
through us, the last stop before
the border, and we fed them,
played games with
the little ones.
We got careless.
The day I woke up and
the air had changed,
I realized it was
a long time coming.
She was sitting on the couch.
She'd gotten up in the
night and made some tea,
but the cup was tipped and
the puddle was cold, and
I recognized the symptoms
from the television
and the newspapers,
and then the leaflets,
and then the radio
broadcasts, and then
the hushed voices
around the bonfire.
Her skin was a dark purple
of compounded bruises,
the whites of her eyes shot
through with red and blood
leaking from the misty
beds of her fingernails.
There was no time to mourn.
I checked my own
face in the mirror.
My eyes were still clear.
I consulted my emergency
list and its supplies.
I took my bag and my tent,
and I got into the dinghy
and I rode to this where
I had been stashing food
since I got to the cottage.
I drank water and set up my
tent, and began to make lists.
Every teacher beginning with
preschool, every job I've ever
had, every person
I've ever loved,
every home I've ever
lived in, every person
who's probably loved me.
Next week, I will be 30.
The sand is blowing into my
mouth, my hair, the center
crevice of my notebook, and
the sea is choppy and gray.
Beyond it I can see the cottage,
a speck on the far shore.
I keep thinking I can
see the virus blooming
on the horizon like a sunrise.
I realize the world will
continue to turn even
with no people on it.
Maybe it will go
a little faster.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm happy to take
questions if anyone has any.
AUDIENCE: One of the
things that's actually
what you referenced
at the beginning
about having to not write the
crazy lady story or something--
I feel there's always a
balance, that it feels more
with women writers that
there's more pressure there.
I think of the balances
that you struck
incredibly was this balance
between intimacy and honesty
about oneself, and not
being like "Eat, Pray, Love"
narcissistic.
And I don't know
if you can explain
a little bit about your approach
there, and if it's intentional,
and how you handled
those things.
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: That's
a really good question.
I mean, I'm--
I always tell my
students, you have
to write the books you
want to see in the world.
You need to fill the gap
that's not there, right?
And so the book that I
wanted to see in the world
was I really wanted
something that dealt
with the realities of being
a woman in our society,
and having the female body
and dealing with that.
And so this book has a lot
of viscera in it-- a lot
of liquids, a lot of guts, a
lot of sex, a lot of fluids.
Just, there's a lot of stuff.
And there's also a lot of very
honest discussions of things.
I have a story in here
called "The Resident," which
is about a woman who goes
to a writer's colony,
an artist's colony
to work on a novel,
and kind of has a mental
breakdown of a sort.
And it's physically like
me, but turned up to 11.
So I was like, this is me kind
of but it's not actually me.
It's a fictional character.
But it's a lot of my
vulnerabilities and anxieties
and thought loops.
And all the things that
make up my weird brain
just went into her.
And there's something very
scary about that, right?
Just being like, I'm going
to put this out there.
I'm going to write all the weird
shit that happens in my head
on a daily basis in a character.
People are like, that
character's crazy.
And it's like, oh great.
Thanks.
[LAUGHING]
People get really-- people
have a lot of feelings
about her particularly.
And I'm like, well, that's the
person who's most like me, so.
But yeah.
And so I feel like I just
wanted this collection that
dealt with that in a way
that felt honest and felt
like I was--
I mean, honestly,
I'm only one person.
I can only portray sort
of one type of experience
or one person's
perception of experiences.
But yeah, I just
wanted that honesty.
It was really
important to me to have
that sort of immediacy
and viscerality,
and not sort of move around it.
Because I feel like that's
the thing people like to do,
is they get close to it and
they get afraid to dive in.
And I was like, no, I
just want to be in there.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Once in a
while you read something
where the text just hits
you in a certain way that
couldn't be described to
you in sort of cold logic,
and you just get
an emotional punch.
In the beginning of
"The Husband Stitch,"
you talk about the voices.
"If you read the story out
loud, please use the following
voices."
And the first one is Me--
you, as a child,
high-pitched, unforgettable.
As a woman, the same.
And the last one is listed
as, all other women are
interchangeable with my own.
And to me, that
was quite a punch,
just to hear it that way,
to hear your experience
and women's experience
expressed that way.
And I would just love
to hear what more you
have to say about that.
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: Yeah.
So did anyone here
ever read book
"The Scary Stories to
Tell in the Dark" books?
OK.
So if you've read my book or
if you haven't, "The Husband
Stitch" is a retelling of a
story that actually is not
in that book.
People think it is.
It's like a weird false memory.
So Alvin Schwartz,
who wrote those books,
also had another book called
"In a Dark, Dark Room"
that was actually for younger
readers-- like not teens,
but it was I Can
Read book that was
like equally scary
stories with slightly
less horrifying illustrations.
And there was a story called
"The Green Ribbon" in there,
about a girl with a
ribbon around her neck.
And her husband is always
asking her about it,
and she won't talk to him about
it, and then on her deathbed
he unties it and
her head falls off.
And I wanted to do a
retelling of the story,
and the first story
in this colleciton
is a retelling of that.
It's sort of an urban legend.
And in the Alvin Schwartz
scary stories book,
there was a lot of
stage directions.
Because the stories are meant
to be-- they're folk tales.
They're meant to be performed.
And so when I was a kid,
I was in Girl Scouts
and I did a lot of camping,
and we would tell stories.
And I learned really
quickly that this book
was a great way of freaking
out my fellow Girl Scouts.
And I could read the
story, and then there'd
be a command at the end,
like who has my liver?
Like that story.
And then it would say, like,
grab the person next to you
and be like, you have it!
And I did and it made my fellow
Girl Scouts cry hysterically,
and I was super into it because
people were having a reaction.
Anyway, so I was really into the
idea of having stage directions
in my story.
But of course, I didn't want
them to be like regular stage
directions.
I wanted them to sort
of have some quality
that reflected the
themes of the book
or what I wanted to talk about.
So in the opening
section of that story,
I'm sort of saying--
because in the actual
scary stories book,
they'd be like, if you
read this story loud
uss a squeaky voice
or a booming voice,
or whatever sort of
reflects whatever
the character's supposed to be.
And I sort of wanted to make
a little nod to my experience
as a person who
consumes a lot of media.
I love TV.
I love films.
But a thing that frustrates
me, especially in genres that I
love-- which is science
fiction and horror--
is that female characters are
often very interchangeable
and completely unmemorable.
And so I wanted her to be
sort of slightly referring
to the fact that
we sort of think
of these female
characters like each
of the women being described
in that opening section.
It's like the men have these
very distinctive voices,
and then the women are all
sort of interchangeable.
The irony being that when I read
it aloud, it's me reading it
and it's all the
same voice, right?
But yeah, so I think it
was something I had to do,
which is take a formal
constraint or a formal conceit
in my work and use
it to just create
some kind of narrative energy.
And in that case, making
a point about a thing
I have a thought about
about women in media.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Through my years of
seeing Carmen and her friends
online and on
Facebook conversing
about all manner
of topics, there's
some equivalent to the
stages of grief, which
is my stages of disagreement
with whatever Carmen
and her friends have written.
[LAUGHING]
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
on this one, which is--
well, I don't know exactly what
they are, because they just
made this up.
But it starts with denial, like
I don't agree with that point.
And then it eventually
comes around to agreement.
Not 100% of the
time, but usually
if I sit and read
and think I realize
there is a point being
made that I had not fully
understood before.
But one very
interesting disagreement
in the last couple of weeks
was about what fiction is for.
And one writer said
in an interview
that, I believe he
said, my fiction is not
meant to be political.
I believe that.
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I know.
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: I'm going
to be real controversial when
I answer this question.
AUDIENCE: And some people, I
think, took it as his saying
that no fiction
should be political.
So there's this debate
on what exactly he said.
But I thought it was
an interesting topic.
Is there room for fiction that
isn't intended to be political,
with the understanding
that in the end everything
must be political?
But if you write something
that's just, oh, here's
a person in a boat
who has an adventure,
and you're not trying to be
political about it, is that?
Is there room for that?
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: No,
it's a really good question.
I'm gonna blow up
his spot, because it
was in "The New York Times."
So it's not like it's
private or anything.
It's Andy Weir, who
wrote "The Martian"
and whatever his
new book is called.
"Artemis," I think.
Yeah, had this incredibly
infuriating interview
in "The New York Times"
that just filled me
with a blinding rage.
I lost the ability to
see for like a minute.
I was just like so
stressed out by it.
"The New York
Times" has a series
called By the Book where they
talk to writers about the books
that they're reading.
So it's really
cool, because you're
sort of getting like, OK,
that's a writer that I like.
Here's stuff they're
interested in,
books that are
important to them.
It's a really cool way to
sort of get, a, as a writer,
amping other writers' voices,
and also helping your readers
learn about other books that
they should be checking out
that you like.
And his answers were just--
they were very
frustrating to me,
because everybody he mentioned
except for JK Rowling,
was an old white man.
Most of them were dead.
There was almost zero
contemporary fiction.
It was all like Asimov--
which is like, not bad
but like, I was like, have you
not read a book in the last 30
years?
I mean, it was literally
like that kind of list.
And one woman, and it's like
the most famous female writer
that we have right now, right?
And I was really angry about it.
And then also in the
interview he said--
someone asked him some
question and he was just like,
my fiction is not political.
I just don't believe in, like--
I just don't want my
fiction to be political.
Answered question.
And my answer is, I don't
actually think it's possible.
I don't think it's possible.
Because even thinking that you
can write apolitical fiction
is in itself political.
Right?
So even a guy in a boat
having an adventure or person
in a boat--
who is that person?
That's still a political
choice of a kind.
So no, I actually don't
think those things can
be separated from each other.
And it's infuriating
to me that he
is so uncurious about his
own craft and about the world
that that is his response.
It just really bothered
me, that with that platform
he just wanted to
talk about Asimov.
Which again, Asimov's great.
But like, come on.
[LAUGHING]
And yeah.
So no, I actually don't think--
I mean, and I love a good,
exciting, pulpy piece of art
as much as the next person.
They give me a lot of pleasure.
But also, that still
doesn't mean that-- like,
I still come away from
the stupidest movie
that's kind of just like a
very simple sort of pleasure
thinking a lot about like
the choices that have been
made at every level, right?
And who gets published
is a political decision.
Whose work gets
published and who's
work doesn't get
published, whose work
gets amplified in certain ways.
Who the characters are.
Who is allowed to tell
what kinds of stories.
These are all really
inherently, really fraught
political positions.
And the idea that you can just
write, make a piece of art
or make a story that is
not political-- to me,
it's just utter
folly and reveals
a deep sort of misunderstanding
of what art is.
Yeah, sorry.
I went to that place again.
I was, like, flashing back
to reading that article.
But thank you, it
was a great question.
AUDIENCE: Actually, similar
to something I was wondering,
would love to hear
about from you
about how your work exists
in the outside world,
like outside of the
scope of the work itself,
and what people's
reactions have been
and what impact you've had.
So I read your book
a few weeks ago
when I happened
to be on vacation.
I've also been going
through this really weird--
I have like one little
thing that's just mine
that I do in the
mornings that's for me,
sort of echoes of the
green ribbon story
and like just having one thing
for you, that I'm currently
rewatching the
entire "West Wing"
and listening to a "West
Wing" revision podcast.
It sounds horrible,
but it's actually
surprisingly interesting.
And the show in some way,
and like Aaron Sorkin being
this ridiculously
talented writer,
watching it with 2017 eyes--
for a show that started
filming in 1999,
and how ridiculously
chauvinistic it is.
And it's funny, because some
of the themes are really--
and don't even get me started on
the racial stuff, because, oof.
Anyway.
But even there is this amazing
moment in the first season
that the people in the podcast
go into looking back and saying
where the president and
Leo were standing there,
and they're our heroes.
They're like the
heroes of heroes,
the top of the cream of
the crop of the people,
and they're saying, they're
going, boys, the things
we do to women.
And they're sort
of acknowledging--
like, a lot of your stories
are the other side of it,
like yeah, these are the
frickin' things we do to women.
And hearing it from the
males, they'll be like, yup.
And then they go and say
something inappropriate
to a woman.
So I totally agree that
you can't separate--
like, it is hard for me
to listen to Aaron Sorkin
and be like, man, you're
brilliant but why can you--
you have one strong
female character,
and you're constantly sexually
harassing her on the screen.
Like what the-- what
is wrong with you?
I'm curious how your work, being
such the opposite perspective
and being so strong
voiced in that way,
like how have you found it
has impacted other people
and impacted the literary
world that you live in?
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: Yeah, "The
West Wing" does not age well.
I've also discovered this.
It is true.
Yeah, the sort of idea--
I think what's been
really hard, again,
as a person who consumes media--
like, the media that I'm
most interested in absolutely
not made for me.
The genres I'm interested in are
genres where my demographic is
an utter afterthought, right?
And so that sort
of idea of, wow,
I'm not even being considered
in any way in anything
about this-- even
artists that I love.
I like Aaron Sorkin.
I love Joss Whedon.
Lars Von Trier is a
filmmaker who I adore,
even though like
literally every film
is him taking a woman apart
on the screen for three hours,
and that's like his entire
project over and over again.
And it's really
hard, because those
are artists that mean
a lot to me, whose
work has meant a lot to me.
"Buffy" is really
important to me.
So at some point, I had to
come to this sense of peace
where it's like, OK,
the art that I most--
not all the art that I love,
but a lot of the art that I love
is absolutely not made with
me in mind, and also at times
is actively destructive
in certain ways
and is very harmful
to women, for example,
or people of color or
queer people or whoever.
And so that's been a thing
I had come to terms with.
But in terms of my own book--
I mean, I'm really lucky because
the work that I write is--
I was like, I want
to write a book that
has all-female protagonists.
Most of them are queer.
I want lots of sex.
I want weird genre stuff that
doesn't really have a category.
I want all these
things for this book.
And I was really
lucky that I just
managed to find a
publisher who kind of got
the vision of that project,
because I feel like--
I mean, I once had a story
rejected by an editor.
He gave me this content
where he was like,
there's just no
men in this story.
There are none.
And I said, I know.
I know there are none.
It's about a mother.
She's got sisters.
Like, there was just like--
I was like, I don't--
there's just--
I mean, they just don't--
because it would at
least get mentioned.
They would mention the father.
And I was like, why?
And I feel like that sort
of reversal of perspective
is intense.
It's intense
[INAUDIBLE] deal with.
And I think the reason
people respond really
strongly to my book is
this sense of utter relief
that that is being
sort of inverted,
because we're just so used
to seeing the opposite.
And so in that same way
that I'm also queer,
and whenever I see a
queer character on TV
or hear a song that could be
thought about as a queer song,
I'm just all over it.
I'm like, I will
give it all my money.
I will watch it.
I will follow it.
Because I'm seeing this teeny--
whoops, sorry.
I'm seeing this
tiny place where I
feel even slightly represented.
Or like "Jane the
Virgin" is a show.
I Like, how many liquids
can you see on TV?
So when I see that, I respond
to it really strongly.
And I feel like people
are feeling that way
about my book,
where they're like,
I'm seeing a thing that
I didn't see before.
I'm hungry for it.
I didn't even know
how hungry I was.
Or maybe you did know how
angry you were, but seeing it
is this really exciting thing.
So the response to my book--
and honestly, I
think the political--
even though I've been writing
this book for five years.
Women's lives have
always been garbage.
They continue to be garbage.
But right now it's
particularly bad.
But we're in this
political moment
where suddenly my book is
like extra weirdly relevant,
even though that sucks.
I wish it wasn't.
I wish it was less relevant.
But yes, I think
that's why people
are responding so strongly to
the book, is because of this.
Because not only
are people like,
that's familiar to me
from my whole life,
but also in terms of
just what's happening
right now politically.
AUDIENCE: I just want
follow up a little bit.
I'm curious about how you
think about the line between,
here are the stories that
I've published so far
and a book as a thing that sort
of exists in and of itself.
What was the process like
of putting it together
as a whole package?
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: Sure.
I see you have the short
story advent calendar.
AUDIENCE: I do.
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
Yeah, so I've been publishing
fiction for five, six years now
professionally.
And I've published a lot more
stories than are in this book.
There are only eight
stories in this book.
And it's weird,
because when I was
sort of talking to editors
in the process of trying
to publish it, there was someone
who was sort of interested
and was saying,
well, I feel like you
could add all
these other stories
that I know you've published
but aren't in this version
of the book.
And I feel there's two
philosophies about short story
collections.
A short story collection
is like the last 15
stories you've published, or the
last 10 stories you published
or whatever, or it has
a strong thematic heart
and a strong thematic link.
And for me, when I read
short story collections
I prefer the latter.
I don't like a bunch
of random stories.
I want them to feel like
they're in conversation
with each other
in some capacity.
So when I was in grad
school, I published my--
my thesis, which had the
same title as this book,
only had three common
stories with this book.
And there's a lot
of other stories
that are since retired
in the Disney vault.
I've tied them away and
no one will ever see them.
But I wanted-- because
I sort of realized, wow,
some of the stories I really
like, and other stories--
it's not that I don't
like them, or they're
about something else.
Like, they're not about
women's bodies and sex.
There were themes that
I had for this book
that I wanted the
stories to be a part of.
And if they fell outside those
parameters, I was like, well,
it's for another book.
Or maybe it's a
one-off story that's
not going to go in a book.
And what's really
interesting about that
is as I was wrapping
this book up,
I sort of was writing
brand new stories
and was realizing like, oh wow,
I have a second book in me.
I have another set
of interests that
is related to these
stories in certain ways,
like still lots of sex,
still queer women, et cetera.
But I have different interests.
I'm writing this book now where
memory is a central theme.
And that's not really a
theme that exists in here,
but it's this new
idea that I'm having.
And so it was
actually pretty cool--
because I feel like
when you're trying
to put together a debut book,
it's like that's your focus.
You're like, this is my book.
This is a thing in my brain.
And then you have
it and you're like,
oh, I have other books in
my brain about other things.
And it's a very odd
feeling when you've
been really focused
on publishing
a book for your whole life.
So now I new projects.
And these stories just get--
my editor really wanted
a tight, lean collection.
Two of these stories
are really huge.
"The Resident" and "Especially
Heinous" are massive.
And so yeah, so it ended
up being two novellas,
six short stories.
It's a fairly
average-sized collection.
Yeah, and I just didn't want
to add anything else to it.
And these felt like they
were very tight, and sort of
in conversation with each other.
So yeah, that's why.
But I really like the
result. I feel like this
was the book I needed it to be.
I'm glad I didn't publish
earlier versions of it
with more stories that
weren't as connected.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious
when for you or what
was the book when you
first felt like you
saw yourself represented?
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO:
Oh, like that I read?
AUDIENCE: That you read, yeah.
And when that
happened in your life,
and how long it took
for that to happen.
For me, it took until
I was a teenager.
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean-- there have
been bits and spurts sort
of throughout.
I was a voracious
reader as a teen.
I read a lot of books--
I mean, books like--
I read, like, "Animorphs."
I read all those.
I mean, I read a lot of series.
But I really loved
"Wrinkle in Time."
That was a really
formative book for me.
I mean, I didn't
really get to read--
I grew up in the '90s, so
I wasn't really reading
many books about queer teens.
But in terms of
female voices, there
was like "Behind
the Attic Wall,"
which was a novel that was
really important to me.
You know it!
It's so good.
Yes, it's so good.
OK, we could talk it after,
because it's so good.
And whenever I say to
people who know it,
they get incredibly excited.
It's such a good book.
So that was a really formative
book for me, where I--
I mean, every teenager and
every pre-teen is like, oh,
I'm so gawky and awkward.
No one likes me.
So it's easy to identify
with a character in a book,
because they're all
like gawky and--
they're like, oh, I have
problems making friends.
It's like, yeah, we all do.
Welcome to the club.
Yeah.
And then as I got older--
the work that sort
of really kicked off
what I say is sort
of my voice, or where
I felt like I was
reading work that I
wanted to respond to
with my own work, which
was a very distinct sort
of moment in my life.
I was reading people like
Kelly Link, Karen Russell,
Helen Oyeyemi, George Saunders.
Mostly female writers.
And yeah, it was like short
stories and weird stuff,
and just like felt weird and
had a lot of women in them
and were just really
weird and interesting.
So I feel like there were
sort of multiple steps.
And then also like
in high school,
I had this teacher who gave me--
it was public school,
so we were constantly
learning, like, Hemingway.
And I really, really hate
Hemingway still to this day.
And I would just
yell at every class--
poor Mrs. [INAUDIBLE].
Every class, she'd be like let's
talk about-- and I'd be like,
he's an alcoholic.
I had thoughts.
I was like, he's
horrible to women.
I hate everything
happening-- oh my gosh,
I pulled my mic down in
my rage of Hemingway.
And I was really mad, and
she stopped calling on me
for awhile.
My hand would be like
seriously raising,
and she'd be like,
Carmen, I didn't even
want to hear what you have to
say about Ernest Hemingway.
But she could tell that
I was frustrated by what
we were reading in school.
And we only ever read like one
book by a woman my entire--
we read "Jane Eyre"
and that was like it,
and then everything
else was men.
So I was very frustrated, even
though I loved English class.
And so one day, my teacher Mrs.
[INAUDIBLE],, bless her heart,
came in with a pile of books
from her personal library
and she said, I think
you will like these.
You need to read them.
And it was "One Hundred
Years of Solitude"
by Gabriel Garcia Marquez,
Gloria Naylor's "Mama Day,"
Henry James' "What Maisie Knew,"
Kate Chopin's "The Awakening,"
and a handful of others.
And I suddenly was
also able to just see
what was possible in
literature and what
it was like to write from
all the different places.
And like, I don't know.
I just really-- so
I feel like I had
these stages of self-discovery
as a young person
because of what I was reading,
this very directed thing
to happen to me
like in high school,
and then when I was in grad
school I had a lot of friends
who were sort of like, you
need to be reading these people
because that's what you want
to be doing as a writer.
And then I felt like my
mind was like blown open
and I was like, oh my god,
everything is amazing.
Literature!
It was just so exciting.
So I think it's been
different phases.
AUDIENCE: You
talked about the way
that the stories
here go together.
And I wonder if you'd talk
about the name a little,
"Her Body and Other Parties."
You mentioned "Jane
the Virgin" earlier.
I feel like there's this group
of subversive and thoughtful
media with this sort
of like, yeah, I
know you think of me meme.
"Jane the Virgin."
"Crazy Ex Girlfriend," yeah.
I wondered if you'd talk
about that a little.
CARMEN MARIA MACHADO: That's
a great question, and one
that I have a lot
of thoughts about.
Yeah, I really-- it's funny.
I actually did not watch "Crazy
Ex Girlfriend" for a while,
because the title was
so off-putting to me.
And then something who knows
me was like, no, no, no.
You really need to watch it.
You will love it.
And I did, and I think it's one
of the best shows on television
right now.
I absolutely love it.
"Jane the Virgin"
also, I was like,
what a weird title for a show.
But yeah, I mean, this
story collection--
there's a few reasons.
So I wanted--
I asked a friend, how do people
name short story collections?
And he was like,
well, oftentimes
it's the title of
one of the stories,
but it's a title
that sort of embodies
the themes of the whole book.
If you read a short
story collection,
you'll notice that
usually the title is
a title of one of the stories.
But none of the titles
were working for me
in that capacity.
I was looking at all the titles.
I was like, none of these
feel like a book title.
But I love titling things.
It's like a weird hobby I have.
So yeah, I was sort
of thinking about it.
And then I also was
thinking about this book
that I really love, Ted
Chiang's "Story of Your Life
and Others," which is a book
which if you haven't read,
you absolutely must, because
it is literally perfect
and Ted Chiang is a genius.
It's science fiction, and
it's gorgeous and amazing.
So that title has
that sort of pun,
where it's like
"Stories of Your Life,"
which is the name of
one of his stories,
"and others," which can
be like "and other lives"
or "and other stories."
So using that sort of structure
of "and other stories,"
sort of riffing
on that structure.
So then I had that in mind.
And then I started mashing
my titles together.
I was like, let's see what
key words from my story titles
could be put together
in this structure.
And I came up with--
I think like "Bodies
and Other Parties,"
because women have bodies.
That's in the title.
And then I was, but I feel
like I want the gender
element to be in there.
So then I was like, "Her Body."
"Her Body and Other."
"Her Body and Other Parties."
And I just really liked it.
And then it just stuck.
It's been the title of this
book even before this book
even remotely looked like this.
And I feel like
it also helped me,
because it was something
to work toward--
it was like a
lighthouse that I could
sort of be moving toward with my
work and the way I do my edits.
So yeah, that was just--
I mean, that was just
how I kind of came to it.
But titles are really important.
And yeah, I do think that
sort of quality of like,
fuck you for what you
think of me, right?
That title is such a good--
it's really fun.
And I think that
level of subversion
is really important
and really interesting,
and I think that both those
examples that you gave
are female-driven
properties, one of whom
was a woman of color.
I think that's
important, that sort
of very, very self-aware title.
So yeah.
That's it.
Yeah?
All right, well thank
you so much, everyone.
It was so lovely to talk to you.
[APPLAUSE]